coming up on 5 55 on your monday morning
blue and red flashing lights for the
side of the road and
i'm not talking about police cars a
couple of viewer questions wondering
what is the deal with these things
popping up in various neighborhoods
thanks to glenn
jerry and others for writing in well
larry hadfield from the metro police
public information office says
they call those things real time crime
cameras officer hadfield says metro
installs them in neighborhoods where
there's been a spike in crime and they
think
having both live and recorded video can
help them figure out what's going on
they do also have portable crime cameras
that can be moved around
the video feeds go to metro and southern
nevada law enforcement's 24 7
fusion center so glenn jerry thanks
again for writing in
you can check the online version of this
and all our stories at eightnewsnow.com
when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me it's traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com